[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier president Trump is right now
celebrating a foreign policy win setting
the table for what he hopes will be an
even bigger one three Americans detained
in North Korea are on their way home
tonight they're returning with Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo whose surprise trip
to meet with Kim jong-un has also
produced a specific date and place for
his summit with the American leader of
course my Richardson starts us off
tonight
from the State Department could even
richer make it evening Brett and
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is
returning to the United States from
North Korea with much more of this
summit between President Trump and Kim
jong-un planned
he's also returning with three
previously imprisoned Americans
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo arrived
in Pyongyang spent 90 minutes meeting
with Kim jong-un and returned to his
hotel when he arrived the reporters
traveling with him asked whether he had
secured the three detained Americans the
secretary crossed his fingers then a
North Korean official arrived and
informed him the Americans were free
I appreciate kim jeong-hoon doing this
and Tony Kim Kim hack song and Kim
dong-chul have finally left North Korea
secretary Pompeo says they appear to be
in good health North Korea arrested two
of the men last year the other in 2015 a
US official says the North Korean
government stressed it was a hard
decision for Kim to release the three
Americans and that they should be
careful never to make the same mistake
one congressman says he's been working
with one of the prisoners families to
release him so we feel very fortunate
that this this gentleman is coming back
to the United States well I understand
healthy so in good shape Pompeyo says he
spent about 13 hours in North Korea
describing it as productive he says the
u.s. and North Korea agreed on a one-day
summit between the President and Kim
jong-un that they could extend to a
second day despite expressing his
preference for a meeting in the
demilitarized zone between North and
South Korea
president Trump revealed the meeting is
somewhere else he says he'll announce
the location and date in the next three
days we picked a time we picked a place
for the meeting or summit as you like to
call it and I think it'll be very
successful but as I always say who knows
North Korea and the u.s. still have more
specifics to work out a senior US
official says the two sides agreed to
meet again in person to finalize the
details of the summit while at a lunch
with the secretary a senior North Korean
official offered a toast claiming quote
we have perfected our nuclear capability
it is our policy to concentrate all
efforts into economic progress in our
country this is not the result of
sanctions that have been imposed from
outside the White House maintains us-led
sanctions and pressure brought North
Korea to negotiate the delegation is
expected to arrive in the Washington
area shortly after midnight or sometime
perhaps even well after midnight tonight
president Trump says he plans on being
there when they do as they left
Pyongyang Brett the plane eventually
left North Korean airspace said
secretary Pompeo says he informed the
three Americans that they had finally
left North Korea Pompeyo says they were
thrilled Brett only imagined Richardson
live the State Department rich thanks